dieter nuhr sagt ich widersetze mich dem
zeitgeist ich mache die die glauben
alles zu wissen lächerlich das hat ihn
zum erfolgreichsten kabarettisten in
deutschland aber gleichzeitig auch zum
umstrittensten kabarettisten gemacht
warum das so ist und was das alles mit
politikern correctness zu tun hat
darüber wollen wir heute reden herzlich
willkommen bei philips persönlich danke
schön hallo hallo wie steht's um die
meinungsfreiheit in deutschland so lala
würde ich mal sagen eigentlich natürlich
gut man kann bei uns alles sagen man
muss auch damit rechnen dass man wieder
rede bekommt insofern ist alles gut aber
es gibt ein problem mit der akzeptanz
anderer meinung das spielt im sozialen
kontext natürlich eine große rolle das
heißt wir haben kein problem mit dem
gesetzgeber wie in china mit dem staat
sondern wir haben probleme mit sozialen
medien wir haben probleme mit mit presse
öffentlichkeit mit denunziationen die
formierung etikettierung von
andersdenkenden und unmöglich machen
was hat sie veranlasst einen appell zu
unterschreiben zusammen mit anderen
intellektuellen und künstlern da ist
günter wallraff dabei metzler kelek
boris palmer da wird ein sehr düsteres
bild gezeichnet von der debattenkultur
in deutschland wir können uns das mal
anschauen vielleicht können sie mal den
appell vorlesen ja es geht um von
veranstaltern ausgeladene kabarettisten
zensierte karikaturisten pauschal
verbotene demonstration schriftsteller
deren bücher aus dem sortiment genommen
werden oder vom bestseller listen
getippt werden bevölkerung eingesperrt
whistleblower und enthüller
opernaufführungen die abgesagt werden
seminare oder vorlesungen stattfinden
könnten weil sie gestört werden
verlagerte gedrängt werden bestimmte
bücher nicht herausbringen befreien wir
das freie denken aus dem würgegriff
das ist eine sehr griffige
formulierungen wie ich meine
wie immer wenn man etwas unterschreibt
ist man nie 100 prozent zufrieden mir
fehlt etwas
was ich möglicherweise sogar für das
wichtigste halte in der ganzen sache
nämlich das öffentliche debatten heute
geführt werden mit den mitteln der
etikettierung statt der argumentation
das heißt es wird meistens nicht gesagt
das argument ist falsch sondern es wird
darauf hingewiesen dass der der es
ausspricht falsch ist die person ist
falsch dies rechts die ist neoliberal
die ist kann aber auch links sein
linksgrün versifft oder volksverräter
sein und so wird auf allen seiten mit
den mitteln der diffamierung freie
meinung denunziert wir sind ein beispiel
geben das ist eine recht drastische
schilderung was angeblich oder wirklich
in deutschland gibt pauschale verbotene
demonstrationen karikaturisten die
zensiert werden oder die einzelnen
kabarettisten die nicht auftreten
die einzelnen beispiel die da genannt
werden sind für mich eigentlich nur die
spitze dessen um das es geht also zum
beispiel wenn lisa eckarts auftritt
abgesagt wird in hamburg dann finde ich
die absage gar nicht das schlimmste ich
finde das ist eine redaktionelle
entscheidung die man respektieren muss
wenn ein veranstalter sagt wir wollen
jemanden nicht bei uns spielen lassen
weil wir die meinung über ihn geändert
haben dann ist das möglicherweise sogar
zu akzeptieren die dann ist aber die
begründung ist interessant es wurde mit
dem öffentlichen druck argumentiert in
diesem fall das ist erstmal schon
schlimm
und das was ich viel schlimmer finde ist
das argument was lisa eckert
entgegengebracht wurde nämlich das des
antisemitismus weil es natürlich nicht
zutreffend ist und es ist ein argument
was nur einen zweck dient nicht der der
diskussion sondern der unmöglich machen
der person der der nicht physischen aber
doch in der öffentlichen meinung tötung
der person also die tötung der
öffentlichen person so zu sagen jetzt
ist dieser fall lisa eckert in hamburg
ja für sie auch einer der sie persönlich
insofern betrifft bei lisa eckert immer
wieder bei ihnen in der sendung auftritt
und ich glaube sie halten auch relativ
viel
ja ich halte sie für einen geschlossenen
menschen die ich in den letzten 30
jahren getroffen habe ehrlich gesagt
keine und fassbar eloquente person die
ein künstlerisches lebens verständnis
hat was ich sehr schätze ich habe kunst
studiert und ich habe das immer so ein
bisschen vermisst in der kleinkunst das
wirklich künstlerische das existenzielle
ich glaube dass viele viele teil der
kleinkunst zu recht als kleinkunst
bezeichnet werden und lisa eckert lebt
eine figur in der öffentlichkeit die
verstören soll und das halte ich für
sehr viel schöner als das was kabarett
in den meisten fällen tut nämlich
meinung äußern und andere meinung zu
diffamieren und was sie tut ist viel
existenzieller sie verstört menschen in
ihren ansichten und die die leseecke hat
jetzt vorwerfen das sei antisemitisch
haben wir einfach nicht richtig zugehört
verstehen die das nicht oder steckt da
irgendeine andere absicht dahinter dass
sie nicht zugehört haben würde ich jetzt
auch nicht ausschließen aber im
wesentlichen geht es natürlich darum
bewusst das missverstehen weil wenn man
sieht was sie in meiner sendung gemacht
hat in den letzten drei jahren in denen
sie glaube ich regelmäßig zu gast ist
fast nicht genau wie lange dann dann
sieht man dass das nicht das ist nicht
möglich ist es antisemitisch zu
interpretieren es sei denn man will ist
missverstehen aber man will sie bösartig
diffamieren das ist das ist auch der
punkt um den es geht bei der
einschränkung der meinungsfreiheit in
deutschland dass das attribut nichts mit
der wahrheit zu tun haben muss und das
ist einfach der vernichtung der
persönlichkeit dient jetzt hat sie das
was manche cancel culture nennen ja auch
mal persönlich getroffen in den letzten
monaten und zwar war das ihr glückwunsch
an die deutsche forschungsgemeinschaft
zum 100 jährigen bestehen das können wir
uns auch mal anschauen ein ausschnitt
aus ihrem gratulations text vielleicht
das auch kurz vor lesen das ist nur ein
ausschnitt ist das nicht sogar komplett
wissenschaft ist gerade dass sich die
meinung ändert wenn sich die faktenlage
ändert wissenschaft ist nämlich keine
heilslehre
keine religion die absolute wahrheiten
verkündigt unverständig ruft folgt der
wissenschaft hat das offensichtlich
nicht begriffen
also das war ihre gratulation das hat
die dfg sogar bei ihnen bestellt wenn
man so will diesen glückwunsch und der
sich sehr bedankt weil sie das als
wunderbare definition von wissenschaft
und plötzlich war es weg von der
homepage bis das passiert ja es wurde
aufgrund des öffentlichen drucks auf
grund von ein paar e-mails wurde es
gelöscht
ich glaube man muss der dfg zugute
halten dass sie nicht gewöhnt ist in der
öffentlichkeit zu stehen dass die so was
wie ein shitstorm nicht kannten und dass
die plötzlich jetzt eine kampagne
machten die öffentliche person auf die
sie auf der website zitierten dann
wussten nicht dass sie damit rechnen
müssen dass da die person kommentiert
ich versuche mal den inhalt des sturms
mit meinen worten zusammenzufassen wie
kann man ausgerechnet denn dieter nuhr
der ein wissenschafts feind ist der ein
klima skeptiker ist der in corona
leugner ist wie kann man ausgerechnet
den ein glückwunsch zum hundertsten
geburtstag der dfg sprechen das war ein
paradebeispiel deswegen habe ich den
begriff cancel culture eingeführt weil
es darum ging meine person zu
diffamieren weil ich ich bin politisch
nicht vor ort war glaube ich das ist
relativ schwierig weil ich halt
heilslehren anzweifle von links von
rechts von oben und unten
und das ist für viele ärgerlich die
glauben im besitz der waren heilslehre
zu sein das führt immer wieder dazu dass
dass mich bestimmte gruppen angreifen
und versuchen vom bildschirm zu
vertreiben weil ich den sendeplatz
belege der wie die meinen mit der
falschen person belegt ist und dann
werden eben solche begriffe herausgeholt
wie corona leugner wissenschafts leugner
und so weiter das klingt ja nicht
umsonst wie holocaust leugner sondern
das soll so klingen dass es eine
bewusste assoziation die hergestellt
wird um meine person sozusagen aus dem
kreis der wissenschaftlich glaubwürdigen
oder rational argumentieren den menschen
zu entfernen
tatsache ist er sich nie den klimawandel
geleugnet habe dass ich corona nicht
geleugnet habe
das dass das alles völlig unsinnige
attribute sind und dass ich eigentlich
immer statistischen wissenschaftliche
argumentiere dass es sogar ein
grundprinzip meiner arbeit jetzt können
wir sagen wir reden hier über ein
elitäres problem von paar kabarettisten
die sich eigentlich nicht beschweren
müssen weil sie haben eigene sendungen
im fernsehen also die haben doch nun
wirklich ihr forum
aber es gibt da aus dem letzten jahr
eine untersuchung des
meinungsforschungsinstituts allensbach
die haben herausgefunden dass circa zwei
drittel der bevölkerung meinen dass man
in deutschland vorsichtig sein muss wenn
man zu bestimmten themen seine meinung
äußert glauben sie dass das schlimmer
geworden ist oder war das immer schon so
grundsätzlich war das immer schon so ist
äußerte sich aber nicht in der
öffentlichkeit ich glaube dass der
stammtisch schon immer dazu neigte
andersdenkender auszuschließen früher
war es aber der stammtisch und der
bestand aus acht personen mittelbaren
großer aschenbecher und das war's und
jetzt ist es halt jetzt werden diese
diskussionen in sozialen medien geführt
und dann sind da plötzlich zigtausende
daran beteiligt im schlechtesten fall
und in dem moment fängt das an wirkung
zu erzeugen also was früher am
stammtisch geredet wurde blieb am
stammtisch das heißt es war so eine art
fonds ja dass das war eine das war ein
form des atlasses man konnte da alles
loswerden was man loswerden wollte und
dann verpuffte es an der theke man
sprach in das glas rein unterblieb ist
in diesem glas und da habe ich dass es
jetzt in den öffentlichen medien
stattfindet und das leider auch immer
mehr tageszeitungen die natürlich unter
sinkenden auflagenzahlen leiden meinen
sie könnten ihre lebensdauer noch
verlängern indem sie die das bürgertum
im internet in die tageszeitung
verlängern
das halte ich für eigentlich die
schlimmste entwicklung in dieser ganzen
in den letzten jahren viele
tageszeitungen checken morgens twitter
und gucken was ist am meisten geklickt
worden und das ist dann die meldung die
in die zeitung
und in dem moment werden tageszeitungen
zumindest ebenso diese lokalen zeitungen
diese kleinen blätter oder ich würde das
auch bis hin zur süddeutschen und so
weiter verlängern wollen
das sind blätter die dass die ganz
bewusst wut strömungen aufnehmen und
glauben damit ihre auflage stabilisieren
zu können und das halte ich für den
untergang des journalismus jetzt müssen
wir fairerweise sagen dass hier
süddeutsche hirn der sender jetzt keine
chance hat sich zu wehren das sage ich
jetzt mal zur ehrenrettung der kollegen
und wird vielleicht kann ich einfach
damit belegen dass zum beispiel ein
großer artikel in der süddeutschen dann
über im zuge dieser dfg geschichte über
den deutschen humor und die kläglich
kite des deutschen humors erschien und
in der ersten fassung dieses artikels
stand dass das meine sendung
mitternachtsspitzen hieß und nun war ich
in den mitternachtsspitzen selbst in den
letzten zwölf jahren nicht mal mehr zu
gast das bedeutete dieser fehler ist
korrigiert worden aber es bedeutet
natürlich ganz klar
der autor hatte sich verraten er wusste
überhaupt nicht wovon er sprach es ging
um ideologische vernichtung das war das
ziel des artikel und es ging nicht um
berichterstattung eines journalistisch
informierten menschen das bewies dieser
fehler der im ersten artikel drin war
dass er dann korrigiert wurde ist eine
selbstverständlichkeit aber es war nicht
zu leugnen dass glauben sie denn
wirklich dass es da bei bestimmten
medien leute gibt die sie vernichten
wollen man könnte auch sagen der dieter
nuhr ist eben meinungsstark da muss es
aushalten das einer auch sagt meinung
teile ich nicht
dann würde es ja um meinungen gehen dann
würde mir vorgeworfen dass ich was
falsches gesagt hätte mit einem argument
darum geht es aber nicht mehr werden
attribute zugeordnet also
wissenschaftler corona leugner
klimaleugner das sind ja keine argumente
sondern das sind unzutreffende attribute
mit denen ich beworfen werden vielleicht
nur im ausschnitt aus ihrem programm
anschauen da geht es nämlich gerade um
in dem fall
corona
ein schönes beispiel wie in deutschland
schnitt storms und empörung skulptur
sich entwickelt darf man sowas sagen
wenn mir eigentlich selbstverständliche
freiheiten genommen werden will ich dass
sich wenigstens jemand die mühe gibt mir
das schlüssig zu begründen ist das zu
viel verlangt
ich meine ich weiß ich bitte ich weiß
die menschen wünschen sich jetzt einen
moses der sie aus der wüste führt oder
wie man früher sagte eine frau
aber ich möchte moses gerne fragen
dürfen wohin wir gehen
ich bin nämlich was oft vergessen wird
genau wie sie übrigens der souverän
dieses landes und kein idiot ja und ich
sehe jetzt gerade das schon wieder
einige zuhause hass kommentare sauber
ausformulieren dort [ __ ] als
neoliberale faschisten so links grün
weiß ich alles ja ja aber nicht jede
kritik an sinnlosen einschränkungen ist
eine kritik an den crooner maßnahmen
schlechthin
vieles ist sehr sinnvoll wahrscheinlich
aber aber manches eben auch bullshit und
darüber muss man reden
in einer demokratie ohne dass das gleich
schon wieder als als eröffnungs
diskussions orgie missverstanden wird
auch auf frau merkel möchte nämlich
nicht an öffnungs diskussions orgien
teilnehmen
ich weiß jetzt nicht an welchen orten
die kanzlerin gerne teilnimmt aber ich
bin auch nicht gern georgien wo er es
noch über die öffnungen diskutiert wird
schon gar nicht wenn die kanzlerin dabei
[Musik]
man manche leute sagen man sollte mit
kritik an dem corner schutzmaßnahmen
vorsichtig sein weil da geht es immerhin
um menschenleben und wenn man da
kritisiert dann spielt man am ende
verschwörungstheoretikern in die hände
machen sie sich über sowas gedanken
die sicheren ganzen tag ehrlich gesagt
inzwischen spielt ja auch jeder witz der
nicht über rechte gemacht wird spielt
rechten in die hände das heißt ich darf
ich dafür überhaupt nur noch witziger
nazis machen weil jeder der nicht alle
fünf minuten wird es über nazis macht
ist selber einer
so ist das in dessen und wir haben jetzt
über die korona maßnahmen gesprochen ich
habe einen sehr differenzierten text zu
diesem thema gemacht wie ich mal ich
habe gesagt dass ich nicht gegen die
kurmaßnahme schlechthin bin und dass es
mir im einzel vor habe ich über das
verbot von glaube ich tennis und golf
und so weiter gesprochen beispielhaft
dass zum beispiel meinem tennistrainer
berufs losigkeit verordnet wurde ohne
dass es auch nur irgendein dies dafür
gegeben hätte dass seine sportart
irgendwie schädlich sein könnte sie
findet an der frischen luft statt in den
meisten fällen die spieler um 20 meter
abstand die bälle sind aus filz da ist
nix da hat sich noch nie jemand
infiziert beim tennis ja und das war für
diesen mann eine existenziell wichtige
maßnahme die ihm keiner begründet hat
und das finde ich muss man kritisieren
dürfen das spielt doch niemandem in die
hände der für den tod von menschen
herbei das ja eine eine lächerliche
überzeichnung dessen was ich tue was ist
ihre ansicht über die korona maßnahmen
dem wir uns mit die zum beispiel in
berlin habe ich auch eine sehr
differenzierte man dazu auch da glaube
ich dass nicht alle demonstranten über
einen kamm zu scheren sind
ich komme aus einer generation die
gesagt hat wenn nazis auf einer demo
sind dann gehe ich nach hause und
deswegen hätte ich an so etwas nie
teilgenommen davon abgesehen dass ich ja
gar nicht gegen die korona maßnahmen bin
in ihrer gänze sondern im gegenteil für
die meisten kroner maßnahmen habe ich
sehr viel verständnis
insofern finde ich auch dass man den
demonstranten zu recht vorwirft sich
nicht genügend distanziert zu haben von
von definitiv als nazis auftretenden
menschen da habe ich auch ein problem
mit ja aber noch mal ganz kurz dazu ich
hatte ich glaube sogar in der gleichen
sendung vielleicht aber auch in anderen
habe ich zum beispiel was gesagt aber
herrn drosten
da habe ich gesagt dieses land hat sich
unter die herrschaft der virologen
begeben und das wurde als zitat im
internet verbreitet nach dem motto ich
sei corona leugner der satz ging weiter
derselbe satz ging weiter mit der wert
und das ist gut so
und dieses und das ist gut so ist raus
geschnitten worden in diesem internet
anders das ist dann ist man so weit dass
es dass es ganz klar ist hier geht es um
verächtlichmachung und hier geht es um
vernichtung einer person
indem man ihr dinge unterschied von
denen man ganz genau weiss dass er sie
nicht meint und auch nicht gesagt hat
ich würde gerne noch mal nachhakt ist
das wirklich so dass es da leute gibt
die sie vernichten wollen und da haben
die nicht ganz andere absichten ich sage
mal ganz banal die wollen hat die
klickzahlen erhöhen weil die sind gut
für ihr medium oder für ihren account ja
ich will das jetzt nicht dramatisieren
ja aber natürlich gibt es starke
ideologische kämpfe in diesem land und
es gibt in dessen wachsende extremismen
in diesem land die bereit sind den
andersdenkenden nicht als
andersdenkender zu betrachten sondern
ihn zu verachten ihm zu schaden wo es
geht und ihn auszuschließen natürlich
gibt es das selbstverständnis
wir schauen uns nochmal in ausschnitten
aus ihrem programm daten sind gewaltigen
shitstorm geerntet greta den berg
ich bin gespannt was greta macht wenn es
kalt wird heizen kann es ja wohl nicht
sein
der ju hat sie gesagt wie könnt ihr es
wagen ja und ja wir müssen diese kritik
ernst nehmen
wir haben eine welt geschaffene der
siebeneinhalb milliarden menschen bei
wachsendem wohlstand und wachsender
gesundheit immer älter werden das ist
beschämend
eine welt in der über 90 prozent der
kinder zur schule gehen mädchen wie
jungen aber der klimawandel kommt und
greta will dass wir in panik geraten
nun war panik eigentlich noch nie ein
guter ratgeber
aber natürlich muss was passieren ich
werde weil meine tochter zu den freitags
demos geht im kinderzimmer nicht mehr
heizen
bitte jugend jemand muss anfangen
ja und ich habe auch als schlechtes
gewissen ich bin viel unterwegs auch
flugzeug auch auto weil ich bin toni
künstler ja sicher ich könnte meine
tournee auch gekriegt habe mit dem
segelschiff machen
von ulm nach rostock das geht donau
runter schwarzes meer zypern links
liegen lassen gibraltar ärmelkanal
ostsee schon ist man da ja da hat es
ziemlich viel ärger gegeben weil es
passiert ja hier gab es ja diese seitdem
gilt hier als klimaleugner und so weiter
aber auch dieser text geht weiter und
auch da habe ich ganz klar geäußert dass
es nicht um eine ente dramatisierung der
klimakrise geht die ich auch für
gravierend halte sondern dass es darum
geht nicht billige lösung als als
heilsversprechen zu verkaufen und das
friday future vorgeschlagen haben
die weitgehend darauf hinaus auf das was
wir während des corona lockt downs
hatten nämlich dass welthandel
eingeschränkt wird dass der konsum
runter gehen sollte und ich habe mir
erlaubt darauf hinzuweisen dass der
wissenschaft zu folgen eine gute sache
ist aber dass es nicht reicht wenn man
nur den klimawissenschaftlern folgt
sondern man sollte vielleicht auch mal
auf historiker hören auf soziologen und
auf menschen die sich mit gesellschaft
und wirtschaft befassen und dann wird
man glaube ich ziemlich schnell zu dem
schluss kommen dass wir in den letzten
40 jahren eine noch nie da gewesene in
der menschheitsgeschichte noch nie
dagewesenen entwicklung hatten nämlich
das immer schneller immer mehr menschen
aus der arme und nach oben gerutscht
sind und dass das wenn wir das tun was
frei der flugschau fordert dass nämlich
der globale dass die globalisierung
zurückgefahren werden sollte dann werden
wir damit leben müssen dass diese
menschen alle wieder aus dem prozess aus
dem produktionsprozess rausfallen
und das würde niemals friedlich
vonstatten gehen davon bin ich bis heute
vollständig überzeugt wir haben ein paar
hundert millionen menschen in china und
in indien
und in anderen teilen der welt die sich
jetzt drei reis mahlzeiten leisten
können und die ihnen ganz anderen blick
auf den klimawandel haben als wir
und wenn wir denen jetzt sozusagen
diktators verordnen dass sie jetzt daran
nicht mehr teilnehmen dürfen an dieser
wohlstands industrie dann wird es kriege
geben und krisen die wir so auch in der
menschheitsgeschichte noch nicht erlebt
haben und ich habe mir erlaubt darauf
hinzuweisen
jetzt gibt es ja so ein bild vom
kabarett kabarett macht sich über die
herrschenden lustig macht sich über die
regierung lustig in dem sketch machen
sie sich lustig über ein junges mädchen
eine junge frau die kein öffentliches
amt hat ist es nicht quasi im
widerspruch zu diesem aufklärerischen
aspekt des kabaretts gegen die mächtigen
ich glaube das ist insofern ein immer
wiederkehrendes sehr lustiges argument
weil greta glaube ich im november
letzten jahres die mächtigste frau der
welt war und in einer demokratie ist die
macht beim volk und dieses
demonstrationsrecht bedeutet dass die
dass die menschen ihr machtmittel der
meinungsäußerung des druck machen es auf
der straße wie sie selber das in
anspruch nehmen dh das sind menschen die
macht ausüben das heißt sie können doch
nicht für sich kritiklosigkeit in
anspruch nehmen was ist das denn für ein
albaner dass er völlig albern dass das
zu erwartende überhaupt ja in einer
demokratie ist das volk als souverän
selbstverständlich auch ziel der satire
das ist doch das überhaupt dritten bus
für dich anwenden eindruck dass es einen
unterschied macht ob sie selber oder
märz kritisieren oder ob sie team berg
oder hp kritisieren
ich kritisiere die ja als angreifen oder
sich über die lustig das ist ja ja das
sind so dinge
es wird ja dann immer als angriff
gewertet oder so das ist auch schon so
eine art kriegs vokabular was dann
verwendet wird für eine satiresendung
was ich so gar nicht teilen würde ich
mache auf
witze über milieus denen nicht selber
angehöre und ich greife mich nicht
selber an
aber wenn ich witze machen über über
söder zum beispiel dann wird das ja gar
nicht wahrgenommen in diesen kreisen
die mache ich ja auch bleibt nur völlig
folgenlos halt eben während wenn ich
einen witz macht über kevin köhler dann
habe ich halt ein shitstorm von von
denen die die glauben ihn verteidigen zu
müssen ich weiß natürlich auch warum das
so ist dass es teil meiner generation
die nun sozusagen den marsch durch die
institutionen nicht nur angetreten
sondern wahrscheinlich auch verzogen hat
und meine generation hat da
möglicherweise diese deutungshoheit für
sich beansprucht und wenn ich wenn ich
witze über linke mache wenn ich den
applaus von rechts
das versuche ich zu unterbinden indem
ich auch witze über rechts mache dann
verfolgt aber nicht der applaus von
links das ist schon komisch und das ist
eine selbstverständlichkeit
beziehungsweise wird überhört
ist das dann für sieben kriterium etwas
was sie überlegen bekomme ich für diesen
gag oder diesen sketch beifall von der
falschen seite
ja das ist ein bisschen was wo ich
glaube ich in dessen auch das gefühl der
habe dass diese anarchie humor ja auch
eigentlich hat dass die schon so ein
bisschen kastriert ist dass man jetzt
immer gucken muss dass man deutlich
macht dass man den applaus nicht von der
falschen seite bekommt ja das ist
richtig
all das über das wir gerade reden dreht
sich um die frage was darf man sagen
oder was sollte man besser nicht sagen
das wird im allgemeinen mit dem begriff
politiker correctness umschrieben welche
meinung oder welche debatte wird denn in
deutschland verhindert unterdrückt
eigentlich in allen wesentlichen themen
die wir in den letzten jahren hatten ist
versucht worden die debatte zu
unterdrücken
also ich habe zb nehmen ein beispiel was
jetzt ein bisschen aus dem fokus ist es
gab ja diese debatte um das stickoxid
und auch da hatte ich ja ein shitstorm
weil ich gewagt habe daraufhin zu
weisen dass der diesel möglicherweise
als übergangstechnik ich möglicherweise
gar nicht so schlecht ist weil er
nämlich feinstaub mäßig das beste ist
was wir haben also die luft die an
diesel ansaugt ist vom feinstaub her
dreckiger als das was hinten wieder raus
kommt das heißt diese funktioniert in
dessen wenn er die neueste technologie
verwendet als feinstaubfilter und das
ist finde ich lustig weil uns da diese
ja gleichzeitig als als als
lebensverkürzend dargestellt wurde ging
es um die diskussion stickoxid der
diesel entsorgten der taten mehr
stickoxid aber ich habe damals in meiner
sendung monatelangen shitstorm geerntet
weil ich gesagt habe dass das stickoxid
nicht das eigentlich wichtige ist weil
das unser leben nicht wesentlich
verkürzt werden der feinstaub unser
leben wirklich in wesentlichen maßen
verkürzten nämlich als wissenschafts
find dich bezeichnet werde
wissenschaftlich manchmal gar nicht so
schlecht informiert im gegensatz zu
denen die mich an pinkeln und hatte
damit auch vollständig recht es hat sich
allerdings erst drei monate später
ergeben und dann wurden nicht mehr groß
drüber geredet dann verschwand das thema
einfach unterm teppich und war erledigt
und dann ist passiert was interessantes
der shitstorm bleibt hängen
obwohl man auf der richtigen seite war
und plötzlich galt ich als der
kabarettist der aneckt ja als als jemand
der eine auszeichnung für eigentlich
auch als ich anfing dachte ich das sei
teil der berufsbeschreibung aber es
wurde mir dann plötzlich vorgeworfen
oder dann stand plötzlich in so in
diesen klick bate medien da so standard
merkur oder watson oder was es da gibt
oder soja diese diese diese medien die
halt so versuchen keine rein zu treiben
um klickzahlen in die höhe zu bringen
dann plötzlich erwartet wieder oder soja
und ich wollte eigentlich nie
ich spreche eigentlich fast immer so wie
ich jetzt spreche ich spreche ruhig und
bin eigentlich dafür dass sich komiker
bin
sehr stark argumentierender mensch
eigentlich ich bin so ein mittelding ich
bin gar kein richtiger komiker mehr habe
ich manchmal den eindruck sondern ich
bin auch ein kommentator so halbwegs
also dass es verschränkt sich so langsam
aber sicher ich würde noch mal gern
zurückkommen auf diesen begriff der
political correctness also wie entsteht
das denn wer kann denn irgendwie einen
mechanismus auslösen oder festlegen was
man sagen kann und was nicht
das ist eine sehr interessante frage und
die wird oft als umgekehrt als argument
benutzt wie es gibt diesen diesen diese
menge der menschen nicht dann aber das
ist ja klar das ist ein an eine menge
von menschen im internet die kann man
nicht benennen
die gibt es nicht die werden natürlich
von bestimmten medien die es
unterstützen werden die gefüttert auch
weil die medien das widerspiegeln dann
ja aber es ist natürlich eine anonyme
menge also der der der shitstorm ist ja
quasi eine eine sehr habe ich neulich
gesagt ich fand die die formulierung
wirklich lustig und gut die humane
variante des des pogroms weil human weil
ja nichts passiert es geht ja nur um
psychologie ist passiert kein
körperlicher schaden aber die
funktionsweise ist ja dieselbe menschen
versammeln sich nur nicht mit fackel und
mistgabel in der hand sondern mit der
tastatur und versuchen die psychologisch
jemanden zu überwältigen
und das ist eine funktion zweimal
einheiten also sind wir nutzen jetzt ja
einen sehr starken begriff programm der
in deutschland mit der juden
produzierten begriff ich bin ja
satiriker der aber in deutschland mit
der judenverfolgung
verbunden ist also stammt aus dem
mittelalter schon ja ja natürlich mit
der jugend verfolgen aber eigentlich ist
ziemlich wir wollen sie da jetzt quasi
sein dass das vergleichbar wäre mit mit
judenverfolgung das ist das ist doch
völlig überzogen dass man gleichzeitig
es ist ein überspitzter vergleich es
geht darum dass man dass man die
funktionsweise ist dieselbe menschen
rotten sich zusammen und sind bereit ich
habe ja extra gesagt die humane variante
habe ich ja extra gesagt weil es sich es
geht nur um die um die soziale
vernichtung als wetterschutz dort
funktioniert eine masse rottet sich
zusammen und setzt an zu sozialen
vernichtung und insofern habe ich gesagt
extra die humane variante das
funktioniert so wie auch ein programm
funktioniert nur dass das pogrom in der
richtigen welt funktioniert hat und zur
physischen vernichtung geführt hat und
das will ich keinesfalls vergleichen
ich vermute dass mit aller vorsicht war
warum macht ihnen denn das überhaupt was
aus wenn im internet gibt eine irgendwas
über sie sagt sie können doch sagen hier
als die juckt das nicht wer sich an ihr
rad also natürlich wird man
widerstandsfähig mit der zeit aber es
geht ja auch um darum zu wirken mit dem
sitzt also man muss sich gegen die
wirkkraft des sturms schon wären also
natürlich geht es darum wenn in dem
moment wo mein öffentliches bild so
wählen dass die leute wirklich glauben
würden ich wäre rechts oder
volksverräter oder klimaleugner oder
corona leugner in dem moment wäre ich ja
ausgeschlossen aus der aus der gruppe
der zivilisierten menschen und natürlich
würde dann keiner mehr karten kaufen und
dann würde auch meine sendung irgendwann
nicht mehr stattfinden
dass ein shitstorm nicht zum gewünschten
ergebnis führt heißt ja nicht dass der
versuch legitim wäre ja das ist immer so
ein beliebtes argument und das finde ich
ein ärgerliches argument weil auch ein
versuch
der vernichtung der wird nicht besser
dadurch dass er nicht gelingt ist das
was da im internet stattfindet was man
mit politisch korrekten das auch anders
um umschreibt ist das etwas neutrales es
gibt ja auch manche leute die sagen es
gebe in deutschland zwar eine art
linksgrüne debatten hat sehen sie das
auch so
im journalismus kann ich das
nachvollziehen
ja politik correctness ist ein
kampfbegriff geworden den man nicht mehr
benutzen kann heute glaube ich weil er
erstens von den falschen leuten benutzt
wird als kampfbegriff
zweitens ist er leer gelaufen
durch die debatte also ich halte es
nämlich für gar nicht schlecht wenn
menschen politisch korrekt sind ich
halte auch zum beispiel dass sowas
endlich wieder begriff gutmensch der
sich als negativer begriff etabliert hat
von rechts und den ich für ganz und gar
unpassend halte weil ich es gut finde
wenn menschen gut sind
also ich habe da überhaupt nix gegen mir
geht es darum wenn wenn politiker
correctness dazu führt dass wahrheit
nicht mehr ausgesprochen werden dürfen
wenn das debatten unterdrückt werden
dann fängt sie an zum problem zu werden
wenn aber dann beispielsweise ein
blogger versucht kritik an seinem buch
als überzogene politische correctness zu
verkaufen dann empfinde ich das auch als
sehr ärgerlicher weil das wasser in
seinem buch schreibt irgendwie von von
wie nennt er das dass das undeutsche
irgendwie entfernt werden muss aus
deutschland mit mit mit gewalt auch das
ist ja ich kriege es jetzt das zitat
nicht zusammen das ist ein einziger
aufruf das buch von höcker zur gewalt
gegen gegen deutsches und das ist für
mich nationalsozialistische
wiederbetätigung aufforderung zu einer
straftat sei an welcher stelle haben für
sie tabus ihre berechtigung
da gibt es ganz viele stellen
ich halte tabus eigentlich für gar
nichts schlechtes ist halt
alteingesessene tabus zum beispiel
vermisse ich sehr
also zum beispiel das nazi sein ein
unding war in meiner jugendzeit das gab
es gar nicht dass sich jemand als das
nach der nazi sein war keine option
und jetzt gibt es landstrich in
deutschland wo man mit weißen
schnürsenkeln in uniform mit hitler
frisur durch die innenstadt gehen die
leute gucken sich nicht mal mehr um
und dass dieses tabu gebrochen wird
daran hat die afg natürlich übrigens
maßgeblichen anteil die ja die die
grenze zwischen zwischen rechts und
ultrarechts eingerissen haben dass
nämlich den sehr sehr übel und ich
glaube dass tabus von links und
rechtsaußen eine starke berechtigung
hatten auch links gilt gewalt gegen
menschen sollte immer tabu sein und so
weiter das auf beiden extremen das ist
nicht mehr der fall
auf beiden extremen und diese ganzen
tabus dieter abgebaut werden das halte
ich für eine zivilisations verlust den
wir erleben gerade ich würde gerne noch
über eine ganz andere seite mit ihnen
reden an ihnen und zwar sie haben kunst
studiert und sie sind auch ein recht
erfolgreicher fotokünstler und wir reden
da nicht drüber sondern oder nicht nur
darüber sondern schauen uns das auch mal
an
vielleicht können sie da zwei worte dazu
sagen ja ich bin ja reisender und
beziehungsweise ich ware reisender bis
corona kam und ich halte die erkundung
eines lebensraums eigentlich für meine
meine künstlerische aufgabe die
hinterfragung eines lebensraumes und das
hat viele facetten
die politisch verbale auseinandersetzung
mit der jetzt zeit ist mich nur ein teil
meines schaffens natürlich nicht für die
menschen ist dass das was eben die
meiste außenwirkung hatten dadurch
ist der sichtbarste teil für mich ist
das nur eine von mehreren teilen die ich
habe und ich reise durch die welt und
versuche der meinen lebensraum zu
erkunden netzartig das heißt vier oder
fünf mal im jahr 30 los und bringe
bilder mit ich habe gemalt
bis mitte der 90er jahre hat dann
angefangen mit der kamera zu malen und
beziehungsweise meine bilder zu finden
auf meinen auf meinen reisen und jetzt
wo krone das reisen verhindert fange ich
an mit dem was ich an an bildern
gesammelt habe in den letzten 20 30
jahren zu arbeiten die bilder zu
kombinieren und jetzt sieht man hier in
diesem bild aus der halo buch den in
vietnam zum beispiel wie das bild der
der landschaft langsam in dieser
vietnamesischen wand verschwindet wie
auch in unserer erinnerung die bilder
verblassen und zeit sichtbar wird durch
einmal zu verstehen wie sie dass das
gemacht haben also für mich als laien
sieht es doch so aus als ob sie zwei
bilder übereinander geblendet hätten
einmal diese landschaftsfotografie und
dann foto ein foto einer wand oder wie
ich das gemacht das ist ein foto einer
wand das sind in der tat überblendungen
die aber nicht nur einfach überblenden
sondern die sind schon noch ein bisschen
anders bearbeitet auch aber da will ich
jetzt gar ins detail gehen dass in der
technischen und ein paar andere gerne
wieder gerne wenn in meinen bildern zeit
sichtbar wird und diese diese bröckelnde
farbe die ich gerne in meinen bildern
habe das sind jetzt die bilder die ich
geschickt habe wo man auch bröckelnde
farbe sieht sind alle glaube ich das ist
in mali genau das
szene in ungefähr in der mitte mali auf
dem land diese diese bäume die
landschaft die jetzt quasi in der in der
erinnerung mit dem bild mit der farbe
verblasst und im hintergrund
verschwindet aber assoziativ immer noch
das bild frei setzt was es vor ort wie
es vor ort war
das ist meine art jetzt in dieser corona
in dieser nicht reisezeit mit mit
eindrücken meiner eindrücke zu
verarbeiten von früher wieder so
eindrucksvoll wie links die sie blickt
damit ziemlich viel wehmut zurück an die
zeit als man noch reisen konnte
ja das ist für mich ein existenzielles
ding gewesen essentielles ding ja auf
jeden fall aber hier ist in nepal das
ist schade das ist ein baum der bei berg
der direkt vorm annapurna massiv liegt
und sehr gern nach asien und auch ein
anderer kontinente also ich war überall
in allen kontinenten war ich nicht ich
war natürlich nicht überall aber ich
versuche überall hinzukommen wo man hin
reisen kann
und das tut mir sehr weh dass das im
moment nicht geht ja weil sie mir auch
eine distanz verschafft ich finde dass
das wichtigste was reisen macht das
distanz zur eigenen lebenswelt
ermöglichen und ich glaube das ist auch
das was in der debatte die wir gerade
führen fehlt ich glaube dass sehr viel
von dem wie ich die dinge sehe daher
kommt dass ich relativ in der lage wenn
von außen drauf zu gucken dh wenn man
aus indien nach hause kommt und gerade
noch den geruch von einem fallenden
körperteil in der nase etwas geradezu
traumatische wirkung hinterlässt gerüche
die man nach tagen noch nachvollziehen
kann da kommt man nach hause und fragt
sich worüber ihr eigentlich gerade
diskutiert wird insofern ist das reisen
auch glaube ich eine wesentliche ursache
für die distanz die ich zur eigenen
lebenswelt habe sie sind ja ein sehr
politischer mensch in dem was sie im
kabarett tun
ich höre da so ein bisschen raus diese
bilder die sind zunächst einmal einfach
malerische bilder ästhetische bilder
aber diese diese botschaft
erweitere dein horizont und schau mal
aus einem anderen blickwinkel auf die
welt und auf deutschland die steckt ja
schon auch drin
das ist bei mir beim beim reisen mit
sicherheit teil des konzeptes ja aber
nicht alle botschaften sind verbalisiert
also doch wichtige botschaften die die
sich besser in bildern ausdrücken lassen
dieses bild ist jetzt nicht so exotisch
das ist in spanien das ist auch ich habe
extra jetzt bilder genommen die
irgendwie zusammenpassen ist auch wieder
eine wand in spanien wo der der fleck in
der wand so aussieht wird das mehr gegen
die felsen spritzen und es sind bilder
die der natur bei ihrer tätigkeit zu
schauen nämlich beim sein und dieses
einfach meditative sein hinschauen
erfahren und zu lassen
das ist etwas was in unserer
gesellschaft die durch tempo
gekennzeichnet ist ich konfrontativer
auseinandersetzung sehr viel zu kurz
kommt und ich habe sehr viel übrig für
diese art der der stillen der stillen
aufnahme von dem was leben ist und ich
glaube dass das eigentlich entscheidende
im leben nämlich zur welt kommen
aufnehmen und wieder abgeben
einfach sehr viel langwieriger sehr viel
sehr viel ruhiger ist in einem an ganz
anderen fluss sich befindet als das was
wir politisch besprechen entstehen diese
bilder so spontan aus dem bauch raus
oder sind sie einer der diese bilder
ganz bewusst komponiert ich will da und
da so den riss haben das soll das
ausdrückt also wenn ich die bilder dann
mache überlege ich mir natürlich wie sie
am ende aussehen sollen das heißt wenn
ich die bilder zusammen setzte dann weiß
ich dass die einzelbilder nachher
zusammen passen sollen wie sie nachher
aufeinander liegen werden usw
aber hier ist zum beispiel ein bild aus
georgien eines der schönsten reiseländer
der welt so ein bisschen so wie
österreich 1810 man kann jetzt wieder
hin reisen im übrigen was ich sehr
empfehlen würde leute die da waren
glaube ich werden mir zustimmen dass es
einen einzigartigen naturerfahrung
möglich ist auch politisch im übrigen
ganz interessant einfach weil georgien
ein aufstrebendes tourismusland war und
in dem moment wo coruna kam das einfach
auf null zurückgesetzt wurde und wir
dann mit in mail kontakt sind wir mit
den leuten mit denen wir in georgien
zusammen waren und die da geht es darum
die mahlzeit für den nächsten tag
zusammen zu kriegen das sind andere
probleme als die die wir gemeinsam
diskutieren meistens und solche menschen
haben natürlich auch einen anderen blick
auf globale probleme wie klimawandel
oder so wenn es wenn man nicht weiß was
man am abend essen soll dann rückte
klimawandel als problem im hintergrund
und wird als als luxus problem angesehen
er was er natürlich nicht ist ja aber
man muss das in betracht ziehen wenn man
globale probleme in den griff nehmen
will dann muss man sehen wie wird das
den global gesehen dieses problem ja und
wenn ich dann sage dass das bei uns
möglicherweise der umgang mit dem
problem des klimawandels sehr kultur
zentriert ist und sehr aus wohlstands
zentriert ist dann ist das grundstück so
starten anstatt sich mal zu hinterfragen
und zu fragen
dann ist was dran an dem was der mann da
sagt und wenn ich dann wenn es das
falsch sehe dann bin ich gern bereit
meine meinung zu ändern
wer sich die bilder anschauen will und
in berlin lebt oder nach berlin kommt
der kann das bis ende oktober tun im
auswärtigen amt ist die ausstellung
ihrer bilder derzeit in der galerie
geyer und teuer
das ist neu am schinkelplatz direkt
nebenan quasi vom auswärtigen amt kann
es teilweise wirken die bilder in in
realität dann noch gewaltiger war die
sind teilweise auch richtig großer bis
auf zwei zu zwei mal drei meter oder
drei mal drei meter oder manche sind
auch klein es ist unterschiedlich kommt
auch das motiv war interessant auch
diese facette von ihnen kennen gelernt
zu haben das war völlig persönlich heute
mit dieter nuhr herzlichen dank herr
durften zu hause bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]